yeah hello welcome to this video this is
a tactics trainer video but the summit's
from its leech as I kind of honor this
light chest leeches someone suggested
that I should do a tactics trainer video
on that side so why not I have
absolutely no experience there I just
fired it up and I put it on heart at
least so um yeah let's do this
okay I'm it's black to move I'm not
giving up
cane idea three check looks normal
I'm starting with the rating of 1500 so
it's um just just blank let's say yeah
93 this win right I'm winning the Queen
if he takes with the Queen Queen e1
check Queen f1 Bishop page to check wins
the Queen best move okay so checking yep
and this one and winning the Queen okay
so what is this my personal rating ayah
here there's a graph okay interesting
1690 uh-huh
interesting and it also has a statistic
here which is not in the screen at the
moment okay anyway I don't think it's
that important okay let's continue let's
see best move for Wyatt yeah most
obvious move is this book is six check
check then captures first okay six check
ticks and then I guess Queen c6 check is
the key move yeah this is meter rook
Asics takes on c6 ever sorry rook a6 be
a six Queen c6 check King b8 Bishop c7
check King c8 push should be six
chocolates when
okay we can take here and now not queen
a6
even though just that win as well it
might earth yeah it does win as well but
queen c6 just nothing wrong with this
move Queen c6
queen a king a7 their special p6
checking b8 Queen c7 and create made a
queen a7 mate and this is the quickest
you should be c7 check where's there
quicker way no okay
one way is enough check check and mate
this is the typical mating pattern here
with Queen and Bishop okay so next one
oh so why not Knight 67 winning winning
the house that's kind of weird
Bishop c7 is also interesting yeah
that's actually better if I go Knight c7
king f7 Knight a eight I mean this is
maybe just an exchange but Bishop c7
wins the Queen Bishop c7 Queen d7 96
check yes that's better
now we have one the Queen here for just
two minor pieces okay so where's the
next one continue no that looks like no
okay okay age seven is probably not
going to work queen g6 black has no
counterplay that's always neat if they
don't really have any counterplay queen
g 6h 6 then f 6 this looks very
threatening but is it the best sister a
question
queen g 6 H 6 f 6 hmm not entirely sure
what the threat is actually with this
takes on g7 oops g7 Queen age 6 k g8 is
this mate don't see it yet
I have it's hard to believe that there's
something better really I don't see any
other great idea
okay I don't want to look for ages now
and let's give that a go
I have six if if he goes rook f6 Knight
f6 Queen takes then rook h6 is winning
yeah it really should be right and this
is the winner wins the Queen King g8 as
Queen yet okay so got that one right
let's do the next one
oops an opening position yeah most
obvious move is Queenie one why why
isn't that winning Queen e1 F 5 F 3 and
resigns
it does the those puzzles that look like
okay very very simple they they usually
have some kind of nasty idea and then
it's not that easy okay okay okay okay
okay you can actually one thing is there
is night c7 mate if the black queen hour
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
the the question is I mean but why is
Queen e2 not winning this would be
interesting to me why isn't that winning
I mean winning as well
and v f3 it should win okay I have
spotted that Queen a force is even
better but here Queenie 4 is pretty
strong the text the knight takes the
Queen and if he takes it that's 97 mate
so that is that is really strong now
with the Queen I didn't get the White
Queen e2 wasn't working really really
don't don't know why okay so next one
yeah first ideas like a way to admit no
not so quick what is this actually we
have one day we are the exchange down
first ideas like Bishop f7 Bishop f7
Queen f7 Knight c7 check but this is
ultimate lame
oh wait wait wait this is interesting
because we will actually win the Queen
if he takes it ha
so this ship f7 Queen f7 97 check King
seven this Bishop g5 check I'm winning
the Queen okay that means after Bishop
f7 he cannot really take king he 7s
Bishop g5 winning so they has has to go
after Bishop f7s to go King to g8
King the edge but do we have anything
great then Bishop g5 Bishop e7 home ok
it's not that clear
yeah that's not that easy at least I
don't see it at the moment I mean I
don't need to meet necessarily if I'm
like let's say then let's say I win the
night on c2 that would be totally enough
but I don't see how that would work
Bishop f7 King D 8 I mean just removing
the knight cannot be the solution
don't don't see it I really don't see it
what is the point here
okay that's not let's not be too focused
on that Bishop of seven who maybe there
are entirely different ideas that I'm
not seeing
it's well okay the light is hanging yeah
I don't really see a great idea there
hmm
it feels like I'm overlooking something
relatively easy something easy
well I actually I actually do we should
be six there should be six ha ha yeah
candidate moves you have to look at all
the forcing moves ready there should be
six is that it's the thing
Queenie six verse 97 every six is not
possible yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and if
the Queen takes on before the screen f7
shaking yet Bishop you fire okay so
Bishop is six let's look at this again
Queen is seven then I am shaking on f7
King G seven Queen f5 check yeah and I'm
winning this yeah this is a winner
wow that was tricky
was tricky
I mean it took me to fill off to me long
time to see it but still I like it
should be six is a nice solution Oh
what is this I don't quite get it
just night h2 is winning huh what is the
point
night age to check Keaney one group g1
check King D to look you one wins the
Queen what is the point where is there
is this more of a trap thing you can
screw up I mean some other continuation
that looks good but does not work I
don't get it right edge to just wins the
house okay yeah they have to be has to
be something easy in between continue
like to move here
yeah I have to say that I like those
here those puzzles because what chest
handbook is very very tough it can
really be frustrating at times
and here you at least with those first
couple of position that fields kind of
kind of doable even if you are not in
the absolute best of shapes let's see
what about this like here we are palm
down we might have something against the
king
Loup cheeks b5 as a move that comes to
mind TX Quincy to check look after will
take it is that a nice one actually it's
it's rather rather cute look B 5 CB 5
Quincy to check rook F to Lord taketh
Bishop c5 check winning the Queen rupee
5 CB 5 Quincy to check King H 1 Bishop
d6 and the queen is attacked by the rook
and this Queen edge to mate and black
and white has no check that's very nice
yeah King H 1 Bishop d6 I liked even
better because it's with the silent
movie yeah it was nice
ok so my rating is up to 2250 let's do
another one
okay what's this
I don't
again I don't get it isn't that just
made Queen a1 check King edge true king
of two Queen a one shaking h2 King f2
White has no check you're threatening
Queen g1 made and I don't see how he
prevented there's no check I don't see
why it won't work
come on yeah seems to be okay and now
king of two and there's no check I have
to use the King actively yeah that was
protected yep that wasn't too difficult
I have to use the King aggressively okay
so next one that looks like weak back
rank issue a weak back rank issue thing
okay let's check this I mean black it's
black here right immediately what
irritates me is black is a huge material
up and should probably win with more
than one continuation I don't really see
what the problem is anyway with a move
like let's a.m. and now queen a2 or
something why isn't that winning
probably it is winning but why are other
moves not winning with strange bit
strange Queen made on ebon also is an
isn't thing that should be kept in mind
this idea yeah cookie Queen e2 Queen c3
and somehow white hangs on it doesn't
feel so clear
let's create hula how despite this
really Quincy only Quincy 3 and then
then Queen f5 probably with that idea of
made I don't like that position
I mean don't like that puzzle blankets
probably winning with my every move I
mean you're an exchange I took powers up
why why is this a puzzle in the first
place why it's not having a threat any
any anything nothing even though I think
that probably what I said is is right
queen angel
yeah it is right and now I was thinking
Queen 85 ok Queen 85 he can go Queen III
or is there a better continuation a
Queen Queen to be one comes into
consideration as well and this rook t1
down
Queen a5 Queen III f4 and game over I'm
okay still continues here okay if you
take a five there's also Group C 1
what I don't like is that any move wins
here kingi maybe not hey Quinn take
serious winning it's just an exchange
and and everything up
I know it's actually taking taking a
true create will win the bishop in
addition so that it's definitely a win
Rupert e8 for Luke t1 yes no I cannot
avoid worked in one Roxy one but drew
create will win as well this is this is
what I'm talking about
why do I have to find a move here still
this is not good even work take c1 is
winning
okay that is right it seems to be still
I mean every move wins I really hope
they wouldn't have counted this as as
wrong if I would have done something
something else because I think it should
stop much much earlier really should
okay I need to need a small break a
smallish break here yeah came back here
to make a quick call so let's do a
couple more power
what a weird position is that and why is
Queen c6 check not winning what is this
the problem should get harder every time
I really wonder what is this okay maybe
what 27 or M is Mike we trapped
maybe I mean the whole position is
completely bonkers there with the King
on the two everything is wrong
but anyway Quincy six check let's let's
have a look there it's cannot it has to
be Queen d7 now any other move I'll take
with check and well
Quincy six check Queen d7 Queen takes a
a check kingi seven yeah why why isn't
then let's say 95 not winning it should
be at leader this I'm an exchange
upright I don't get it I don't get it I
take it and then 95
but I really have to do that right
otherwise I mean my queen is trapped I
have no other move and the Queen age 8
is not not really great or no but 95 is
okay wait wait wait
not 94 check maybe he takes e4 and
Bishop takes e5
but 65 to age 85 I'm a piece a bright
light if 534 check de for Bishop takes
e5 Queen h8 Bishop age 85 I'm a piss-up
okay path of field okay that's
interesting and what is the solution how
do I actually look at the solution here
with this should be 8 ok I am NOT ok of
course I don't understand why my
solution is not my idea whatever it's
not working why not
well it's 95 not working I cannot really
review it here right I have an analysis
board okay I'm kind of exploring things
here 95 but I don't have a computer here
right that I can switch on No so why
isn't this working
I was thinking if he takes here I think
here I'd have an exchange up it should
be mean that this is enough so that's
not working
the Queen has no moves really either I
get to check our check with g6 or
whatever twinken on so what is that what
is the point I thought this maybe takes
takes check other takes I check here and
I'm a piece of so why why is that not
winning I mean maybe this position isn't
so clear but but then well then this is
a weird thing I don't get it why isn't
why isn't this winning
I don't know I don't know maybe you tell
me I'm really don't know well let me
check let me check this I'm going to
check it with an external program okay
I'm back I added briefly check it with
the computer because I didn't didn't
really get it
things okay Bishop b8 this move is
indeed stronger and therefore okay it
should be the solution but this is the
case where 95 is also probably winning
because blacks best line relatively
speaking is this and then is playing
with an exchange down White has well
white should win with good technical
play but it's not as winning as Bishop
p8 so this is one of those puzzles that
I find slightly questionable I think
there should be a very clear solution
and not something else that is very
close to a win which disease I mean
technically speaking white should win
it's just clear that Bishop b8 is it's
even stronger yeah that that's true so I
understand that this is kind of wrong
but what I did but it shouldn't be a
zero point move let's say or something
that gets you deducted points for
example if I know a student of mine
would would come up with with this
either solution I would be satisfied
yeah because the winning chances are
excellent after that and overlooking
this kind of Bishop BA ders well it's
better to see it but it's not terrible
so reducing or deducting points as not
not the right okay I think okay I hope
you enjoyed it that was some a little
bit simpler set of technical problems
than the usual ones of chess temple and
I hope it was quite enjoyable thanks for
watching